okay one of the biggest justifications
that the open everything crowd
has given for why everything should
always have been open throughout the
pandemic
this includes trump republicans fox news
hosts everybody
the justification was quarantines
guidelines
so-called lockdowns even though the u.s
didn't have lockdowns
that is causing suicides to explode
suicides are way up except we now know
that
it was completely untrue we now have the
suicide numbers from 2020. we can know
whether that actually happened and the
thought went sure
people might die from covet if things
are open but people will die by suicide
if things are closed
trump endlessly said it suicides are up
suicide suicide here's one example
a prolonged lockdown combined with a
forced economic depression
would inflict an immense and
wide-ranging toll
on public health this includes a sharp
rise in
drug abuse alcohol abuse suicide
heart disease and many other dimensions
of physical and mental well-being
moreover many patients have put needed
medical care on hold
creating entirely new hazards for public
health
our country has suffered the world has
suffered
here's another example of trump making
the same claim
on the ihme model which is now showing
134 000 deaths by august doubling its
previous prediction
are you concerned that that's happening
because some of these states are
relaxing guidelines
no no i'm not because that that assumes
no mitigation
we're going to have mitigation no we're
letting people out but
the fact that we're letting people go
and go to their jobs they have to do it
you know if they held people any longer
with the shutdowns and
you're going to lose people that way too
and you already have i'm sure
but between drug abuse and i mean they
say
suicide a lot of different things
suicides
way up i could play a dozen two dozen
and three dozen 50 100 of these clips of
trump and other republicans talking
about
suicide suicide suicides suicides were
down in the united states in 2020. we
now have the numbers
they claimed it without evidence lots of
people fell for it many people repeated
it
and it simply was not true suicides in
the united states
decreased in 2020 according to early
data from the cdc
suicides in 2020 believed to be
the lowest in five years roughly on par
with the lowest in six years according
to the new cdc data
suicides declining 5.6 percent
in 2020 from 2019.
now just because they were wrong as they
almost always are doesn't mean there
aren't
issues of concern here this doesn't mean
there won't be
serious long-term psychological effects
from the pandemic
there will be ptsd agoraphobia
the continued feeling that the world is
dangerous and
you know we have to stay home we have to
stay hidden
it's a long list and there will be
serious consequences for years and yes
part of it will be from the isolation of
the pandemic
part of it will be from people getting
coveted and dying
or having a friend or family member who
got coveted and died
but the notion that the covid prevention
efforts
did more harm than good because suicides
are way up
is simply not true the economy is
recovering very nicely the u.s
government should have done more during
the bottom
no doubt about it but we are seeing that
the quote lockdowns which weren't
lockdowns did not do irreparable harm to
the u.s economy it did change the
economy the economy we have at the end
of this year
is going to be different than the one
that we had in january of 2020 no doubt
about
it the other issue just because death by
suicide was down in 2020
doesn't mean any great victory it was
down 5
nearly 45 000 people still died by
suicide in the united states in 2020
that's horrible that has to be dealt
with that is still a crisis
but the point is suicide didn't explode
because of the guidelines that were
recommended by public health experts
one other note suicide could be down but
depression could be up
and we still need to deal with that that
also has to be looked at so this is not
about
everything they said should have been
ignored it's about
one of their main empirical claims
suicides are way up was
factually wrong one other note the
takeaway for me
is not the isolation and the guidelines
and the distancing aren't so bad that's
not really a
interesting takeaway it's not an
actionable takeaway for me it's more
about
we should have a more flexible system as
a matter of
status quo so that people who do better
with work from home
can do it we have the technology for it
there's
there's no reason not to and
increasingly if you look at what's
happening happening with office space
demand
it seems as though that is a change that
will become
at least potentially semi-permanent in
the economy
but they were wrong again no explosion
in suicides
suicide's down five percent now if you
or someone you know
is not doing well maybe considering
suicide
there are free resources available okay
the national suicide prevention lifeline
you can call it 24 hours a day
800-273-8255
okay free 24 hours a day 1-800-273-8255
available to you make it available to
anyone you know
the crisis text line if you don't want
to get on the phone with someone if you
prefer to text
that's fine you can text the word
home to 741 741 that's the 24
7 free crisis text line there are
resources available uh make sure you
know them make sure other people you
know
are aware of them